were some fool partying welcome to the
whirlpool podcast we got rodeo toys
right here man shiny man what up how you
guys doing it without two pounds right
six six
I love really hell yeah man where am i I
wear myself to date but you know that
it'll really count 288 good yeah man I
was like yo one bro
two weeks ago eating a lot what's up
fool no no sleeping with pie we got Lisa
right here
Byron Bowers yo what's up from Atlanta
Georgia that's right we here we laughs
yeah at Byron Bowers is my Instagram
photos you wanna know I can't even say
what's up food like you do what's up boo
shut it out look out what's up ooh it's
beautiful
we got Byron Bowers right here we got
the law here man he was at my wedding
yes right that's right man we were deep
de regarder showed up well uh the first
time I met you I think well I remember
when I met you I had to be like 2010 I
was on the run I was doing a whole bunch
of Latin roles I just was fresh to LA
and I discovered these lat oh this is
dope you know I mean y'all paid gas
money we go out people stare at you you
know I mean my first international
audience I will get stared stared at
with guys with cowboy boots and booked
an artifact yeah man I don't know how
Puerto Rico do it in New York but but
Mexican we got [ __ ] little rules over
here that pay 40 bucks cetana rules pop
up it's like black rooms in Atlanta
that's how black rooms are you know you
know I know matters a lot like you can
make a living in a lad night without
your be known that's true there's a lot
of a lot of comedy over there
but I'll leave there's a lot of [ __ ]
like a lot of I don't know when it
started but somehow somebody's decided
you know what I can't be doing the
Comedy Store pretty bucks
yeah Latino comedian man they want to
get paid man or they feel they need to
get paid some of them feel they need to
be paid and man they shouldn't be in the
room that's true that's true
it was interesting shark for me to do it
on the west coast because before they
and I was in like Brownsville and Laredo
you were there too yeah I was in so you
know no you know rema northa I don't you
know a black dude brought me down black
promoter he spoke Spanish his wife I
know his name Carlos Carlos Kody you
were cowboy boots that was cool man it
was a good experience and yeah that's
when I started I got a glimpse of
Mexican racism
oh yeah is there yeah like Latin or like
mexican-american races oh yeah there is
my pleasure the darker Mexican a man who
everybody Joe Camino it was that's my
story looks like it's racist between
Mexican between like it's almost darker
someone poor but these words of they're
poor and they come from the country well
what I learned that day I was in Laredo
now I was in McAllen it was 2008 and it
was anti Obama rally going on right
outside my hotel no it's my first time
walking this is my first time in Texas
right and that was my intro to take Wow
right outside my hotel and then they
staring at me because I'm walking around
like this is cool you know and then in
McAllen I met people from Mexico City
and then they was telling me tradition
between Mexicans from Mexico City and
Mexicans in net southern Mexico she
learned it was lighter complexion and
they spoke differently and all this
stuff and I was like what they tell you
those [ __ ] well you know they
say [ __ ] like oh we delete basically was
saying that we delete of the group you
hear this every live in Polanco I
recently went to pile on right and I was
like
got cheddar you really feel mexico's is
really from there but or it's even like
yeah that you got the hood the same hood
like when I went to Brazil they got the
on the on the heels you got the places
you don't go in Mexico habilis yeah
putting are they they could be colored
um you know to make sure you don't go
there yeah where's the big ones thing is
that it's right it's in Mexico City
right there that's work demo Cardenas it
from I was I was having a the1 which was
north of Mexico City for five minutes
yeah going south you could see the
beautiful what gun yeah but I mean not
even the pyramids but the the hood right
that's painted and it's these beautiful
colors it's like a mural it makes you
want to go over there but it's for the
tourists to not realize how poor the
area is oh okay no I mean that's what
it's for it's to hide it what's go city
you can see all that [ __ ] yeah
everything that's like beautiful and
like rich and ostentatious and the
ghetto ass you know you can see that two
or so when you play it to a passel man
you go to the left it's like it's like
it's like I'm somehow United States know
how to keep the dust in Mexico cuz you
look to the right powder is dusty
brother Bernie trash and then you watch
the left or pass oh it's just dusty
remember we went to that one that little
hill that we went there and El Paso the
last time before that one would like
though right there where the where that
true little trouble yeah it's all gated
community style they're not and then the
other part about passage is dusty as
hell and like you know how Mexico ish I
remember I went to Tijuana those I don't
go but and every time you read something
like that just white people yeah right
so I peek over in the warias Mexico and
I was like oh yeah they chopping it look
like it was just a war zone here was
that that was like maybe three four
years ago my first time in El Paso Texas
it's my first time they found them a
mass grave with a bunch of dead people
like at least 17 or more yeah tomorrow
so yeah man I know they're wired and
this is 1990
my first time there in 1998 1997 1998 I
took a Greyhound bus there and I
remember the comedian um I was
performing Bank read he said I'm from
New York he said um yeah I don't know
you get had our ancient burial ground
next door and everybody died but yeah
man they found a bunch of bodies but
didn't know like I think with Hawaiian I
think what a horror is that week but I
remember going back and I did go with
joy with Dena but I wasn't scared but
there was now a lot of talk about it
because I'm when I was in a pan so that
when we went to that comedian that fat
for chewy yeah and I was talking to her
talking to a lady there and she told me
she were talking throwing stories and
she said that her I'm her brother was
visiting in Mexico and he was kidnapped
and they had him like it they had him
and I can go car the guy was arguing in
the radio with somebody in Spanish then
somebody I guess who had like a la
accent who like a cholo Emily damn dog
get the wrong waffle and um he had the
wrong guy and it said he looked like a
politician they proposed to kidnap or
were a cop any more than him and they
let that fool go they just threw him out
of the car you're worthless and but it's
crazy because she told me that story I
was like wow you you didn't even know
how lucky he was he did you put it
through him and you know and went up to
the real guy afterwards and just told a
mistake you know yeah mostly it's like
cuz even in like posh office buildings
or like apartment buildings in Mexico
City if you let the door guy if you
don't tip out and you don't have a good
team around you know the way home boy
comes lives here humble goes in this
hour from this step to that yeah it
doesn't have a bodyguard like they'll
snatch your ass up that mean what can
you do you know nothing I mean I don't
know is something is [ __ ] up but it
sounds so chill about it you know coming
from Atlanta where what were you go to
Mexico why my girl is a director and she
was filming a commercial down there but
those on though they sometimes they feel
commercials in Mexico cuz it's this you
got a vast colors you got black red skin
see all the way to white nichkhun's and
if it's music playing in the background
like Kendall by the tail which is we
they can shoot a commercial for cheap
you know I mean and you see this going
on a lot so that's how I made my way
down you know because he got his shoes
over there no no Haitian community in
Tijuana yes we was in Mexico City and
they went further south to other
beautiful places outside the city very
beautiful in the food's great you know
your girlfriend does a lot she your
girlfriend well-known director like
she's cute crushes my ego but yeah I'll
travel I found myself travel over here
sometimes you know I mean cuz she go to
adult places you know what comic travel
we get the shitty hotel yeah
when directly travel they get you know
you end up [ __ ] like I mean I'm
swimming on the roof of the pool
overlooking the city and I'm like man I
picked the wrong profession this is
crazy you know so it's cool but you
learn a lot you know I mean but they
were they're very protective they get
transport everywhere you somebody or
scheduling your meals and stuff like
that so it was a interesting way to
travel top-notch handlers versus meet me
in the mirror we just got back from
Lebanon and Beirut and we just were
walking down the street for four hours
we don't know what's going on you know
me these guys with machine guns walking
around and we just like just regular
fool civilians or soldiers ah these are
soldiers some of them cops and they own
tanks in the middle of the road they
just sitting on tanks and you try to
take a picture of them they like you
know you know middle Easterns got a look
that just already kill them you know
even though they don't they could be the
nicest person in the world you know and
they just like move move on yellow huhu
y'all y'all had a baby okay just keep
walking what like four miles everyday
lay out all the time people stopped us
it was like that as direction by that
time we knew where everything was
keep going straight you gonna get
downtown but it's cool well the night
laughing Beirut
nightlife is is if you in your twenties
it's insane it's the Vegas it's the
Vegas of the Middle East that means all
the hijabis come and they take off their
hijab in the party and the party go to
four and then after that after party you
not me but nobody's like doing like
crazy drugs like to them that's getting
loose but anybody doing nothing too
crazy over there you know I mean like
how we do it in Vegas but it's a place
where everybody could fly our and let
loose and it's all that all the music we
don't like it's so Americanized it's
like man am i Glendale good evening and
then when they buying bottles you like
yo the Emirates the Emirates in the
house they just bought 32 bottles of
champagne and it's like oh this will
money is like Lamborghini Ferrari they
flying it cause it's like it's real
money here but real paper
it's real correctly flame hose from LA
huh yeah this talk about that yeah I do
it all them Instagram models they over
there getting it in how your sponsor
yeah it's weird yeah I saw it I just saw
that too and it's amazing that that's
been going on for years for years and it
happens all over the world cuz just
think Americans just like they probably
is getting a few white women but it's
beautiful women in Latin America you're
not mean it's beautiful women in in
Greece and all these women all over the
world they fly over and if you look at
the women Instagram over there they are
done up and it's like oh this is some
beautiful [ __ ] you know I mean the only
drug traffic I met was was was Lebanese
in Latin go back and forth from like
Miami to Venezuela somewhere and I'm
like that's a whole different ballgame
we just got to get it from Oregon yeah
you were a why when you were other and
in Beirut um how did they how everybody
treats you knowing that you were
American and African American oh I got
treated nice um it was when I'm talking
like I'm talking to somebody and they
hear my voice
they always turn in here like oh oh [ __ ]
who is this if I trip is like the rolls
are like not
equal so I'm always tripping and falling
like I'm clumsy people be blowing a horn
baby I see you you know there was a lot
of that going on so yeah it was like to
do her high fives and taking pictures
like we get treated well we could treat
it well I got treated real well when I
was in Holland Rotterdam yeah like I
still really heard my accent
they started quoting American me blood
in blood out
oh yes they were bowing down when I came
to their town like the gangsters they're
like after the show like we smoked a
spliff
one guy a weird could one guy had jack
where'd you go told you like but that do
that head I'm pure like cops here like
some weak tobacco in the blunt but then
he put all hash in there bro like oh
he's a pack of it yeah then I told him
where I was from and and he was quoting
blood in blood out he goes the man if
you were like walk around a neighborhood
because you got rank here already cuz
you're from East East Los yeah
what happened me this guy was like you a
rapper I was like no and he just are
freestyle rapping for like yeah somebody
got the video of it and it was I'm just
staring the battle
yeah I'm just staring like man please
who you approve no I'm like come on man
I'm not I'm not a battle person I mean
get out of here I'm just trying to enjoy
my night he just kept going you know me
just rapping and I was like this is
weird
oh and I'm called [ __ ] there more
times than the past five years in United
States where and yeah I just to take a
picture like yeah I won't take a picture
with this [ __ ] cuz it's so casual like
I was over there saying it to like on
stage so it was weird you know me but
they were happy they said they couldn't
wait to see one huh yeah they couldn't
wait they were practicing the write it
again mm you know jessimae Peluso yes so
when she was there she heard it she was
just shot like just keep it moving
treated like you in the room for the
class members how's that food man the
food's crazy is bananas man that's my
fourth time in the middle of easing yeah
anywhere where's no ice you know I mean
the food pretty much gonna be
yeah that land in Mexico City
Wow you know I mean it's dope it's like
what and then you got to come back to
America and like and like try to find
food to eat that makes sense
you know me so it's crazy to go to these
places I gained by the time I came back
from Mexico I went last year I had to
die but she go to grow hmm well you came
back being with a new man I came back it
hard
I have animals Mary bone marrow the size
of my lead
well gee wait the first time you have
bone marrow right yeah crickets yeah I
seen crickets and I'm in Tijuana by the
when I went to the bakery
it was doing this bakery head up head
I'm like a cover over the pan loosen the
sweetbreads yeah and then they had like
they're good Mexican candy they don't
sell over here you know like the like to
sweet potato that hard it was looser and
then like that though the real real hard
macaroon and all that [ __ ] was cold with
bees and then over there they had on the
side they had chocolate-covered crickets
yep and you ate you ate them something
wasn't quite ready cuz it squirted off
in my mouth lady comes by with the big
old bucket huh little pitch semen
protein you away for one bad joke
cricket never seen a [ __ ] before he was
shot just staring
what kind of poverty you see em be rude
man all the all the people that was
begging for money are Syrian they from
Syria refugees that was sent over and
they took over like 1.5 million which is
a lot here a porker up
yeah with no support no wait no ability
to support and their with their kids
like in their hands with and then they
got this the little palm out and showing
a camera like this like saying something
that I don't even know you know me and I
remember giving a kid I'm out like two
or three o'clock at night and it's young
Syrian kids out there selling flowers
can they hustle on I'm like yo man keep
doing your thing you know and I gave him
a $2.00 bill and and I didn't know that
$2 was rare out there like $2 bills and
I was like man I probably got this kid
robbed or killed yeah yeah I mean so it
is interesting because when I was in
Dominican Republic the kids that were
begging Haitians which was weird you
know I mean and I was over there I ain't
giving you [ __ ] money
annotation was like you know we know
what's going on in America you know we
know that they should not shooting y'all
[ __ ] over there trying to appeal it
was like you know what no the Goodridge
on y'all he's like you know the
difference it's y'all got it we don't
have cuz they treat us unfair to y'all
could still make it
America don't know that man he go $5.00
Toni Dodd yeah you know that's those are
the things you learned I think I believe
if it's possible to every person
especially black you know should go see
these things because some of the stuff
that we trip on will be like oh oh we
kind of like still you know we
privileged in a way we pamper we
complete we complain about [ __ ] is
privilege you know I mean it's crazy
no the the poorest people here are still
richer than poor people yeah other
countries yeah I heard if you make 30
grand a 40 grand you make more than you
still risk apparent there isn't a 1% of
the world yeah that's amazing
33,000 a year my mom if you could eat
McDonald's every day you pretty much
doing good dude they had a girl from El
Salvador dude she was on CNN real quick
and she said that she works at
jack-in-the-box and she came from El
Salvador when she was like 12 and with
that money she's every parent go to the
movies and have a good time invite
that she's happening good yeah I wish
everybody could do that she said she but
she might not go to I'm Kim Kardashian's
pay that much right no no right [ __ ]
about all that she's more than you -
part of me a lot of people here like
they make bad decisions bro with their
money like you know you're you shouldn't
be paying a phone that's more than your
rent
I've done it I've done your copy right
now Russell got you there ain't Russell
Peters I dress it down but it doesn't
look like - what you said it was because
of the band yeah that's why I said
disguise I learned yeah you learn not to
you know it's like this are you gonna
pay taxes so look how quite a guy wait
do I just say or pay taxes taxes come
first you get then America or it would
be rude in America right in Beirut nah
they got knockoffs you know everybody
got one what the bedrock of who's seen
in Beirut ah lovin some lips you mean
like on somebody yeah but they were like
watched they like camels they were they
were like oh want to look like a human
don't move kill it kill with a stump you
know a bang-up job they like cats over
there they look like camels I mean
it's a different bug so yeah I mean when
you grow up when you grow up with
nothing or lack you grew up poor in
Atlanta yeah for the most part or
everybody had more than me you know I
mean they could get the latest thing and
I will get it when they were done with
it
like I still wear hand-me-downs to this
day you know so when you when you get
someone you know like yeah people mess
up they don't pay taxes but it's
different when it's in your hand when
it's in your hand is like okay I know I
said I was gonna do these things but no
let me just try this one thing and then
you can try to die and another and next
thing you know you three years behind on
taxes can you can't be that when it was
the first time you like would like the
first time or we will say when but when
you first got your first like comedy
check or at an actor check we know when
you realize it was like whoa
I'm a [ __ ] ghetto jido today
yeah well that well I got look I had a
job in my early twenties that I [ __ ]
up on I [ __ ] the money up so when I
first made a grand in comedy extra grand
I bought silver you did I bought silver
bullion and I remember a laugh about a
thousand dollars of silver and I
remember I got it
like the point nine nine nine percent
pure silver and I was I'll never be poor
again
I got a their peaceful self and we have
another comedian named Keith Manning
just for when others do buy to buy gold
bullion one and they got it right there
in vending machines Rico that's crazy
Gold is different though although gold
was down for a long time I'm looking for
silver and they still drop and I was
like will I was trying to get something
that you can't easily liquidate anyway
you know just in case arm again come on
you in another country do you need money
you know so that's why I try to buy
those things cuz you know my dad
paranoid schizophrenic doomsday prepper
pay your taxes okay good I'm serious it
broke I decided pay
you know what make Isis look at we grew
up poorer as [ __ ] and taxes come first
man there been so many people who get
yeah that's the way you see I was like
sis I'm down I'm just gonna go on and go
all out and I want to have a kid once I
decide I want to have a kid I was like
let me let me start trying to get my
life together and the first thing I did
was got a California license got a
started support but you got to come you
got to get on the map again and become
official you know I mean that's a little
thing you're in the dark out here for a
while not for a while but I was just
riding Georgia a long time just in case
you know and then you know it's crazy
soon as I got a county license they
allowed people from Georgia to bring
permits use that gun permits that that
could travel back and forth to each
country I mean any any place and I was
like town I couldn't keep my Georgia
license like I have an AR right now go
to the haha what's up fool yeah Oh
coming shows yeah dude August 7th at the
Fox in Riverside and we have Marty and
then August 14th in a shamrock you know
Temecula hit emoji shamrock ok people
I'll be a Jacksonville Florida August
2nd through the August 4th Amarillo
Texas August 10 McAllen Texas August 11
Lubbock Texas August 24th
Lorado Texas August 25th Brea California
August 30th through September the 2nd at
the BRIT improv
check out Felipe WorldCom slash store
for info on all these upcoming show you
have upcoming shows Mondays show was uh
imma be at La Jolla in San Diego
September the first and the day before
that I do my days backwards so that's a
Friday and Saturday come check me out go
to my Instagram and everything a comedy
store you know by the way and then I
might dip down to Tijuana just to say
what's up you know I mean everybody down
there get my teeth clean come back you
know boss you've done it not is here you
could do it do
interesting stuff like that Julie comedy
New Mexico I did man I forgot the name
of the show but I got hooked up with
some comedians down there and and the
crowd didn't even speak English I think
30 percent of the crowd spoke English
and I still got applause break from the
sex joke and uh and cops you and black
people joke so I'm like oh that's that's
universal
that's tight new comedy beer in the
Middle East
I did a comedy in Beirut Afghanistan
from military or what for military in
Afghanistan and Bahrain but this Beirut
show Lebanon was all like regular people
you know I mean locals and stuff who
came to comedy show we dere for like 250
plus night so it was good English
speakers yeah English is a third
language so is Arabic is French then
English so everybody's culture like they
listen to our music they dress and like
our clothes you know I mean so
culturally the jokes all land over there
for the most part you know what I do I
just can't be 100 you know I mean I
talked about like the issues that we
have like if you go over there and talk
about issues that Latin have over there
like real issues that will get it more
because they people they pay attention
more to international they do nothing
they know everything and they go through
the same hardships you know I mean so I
was like I'm just gonna do this I ain't
worried about changing nothing the dirt
some of the dirty stuff hit hard and
then some of it was just like oh they
don't understand cuz it's still
conservative over there so it's
interesting on when they were laugh-in
like some sometimes girls was afraid to
laugh sitting next to their guys and
vice versa because they is like oh I'm
telling them myself but it's finally see
women like fully coverages just just
died laughing overskirt joke you know
man
so yeah everywhere I've been a performer
that's clearly over there they're
telling you to you pretty much to say
whatever you want but now you're gonna
like um meant like people are getting
people are like when you go to a car
like I'm a bit to do I don't a lot of
colleges and they never told me - I'm
not saying there's not say that I
figured that you know there ain't no my
comedy man yeah you didn't book me
because I'm clean yeah that's the thing
and like and I and then when I get there
it goes you know I'm not gonna change
I told a lady with the last gig I deal
with an Arkansas and I told her lady you
know I could see whatever I want right
he goes yeah they whatever the hell you
want you know they're you know you you
know who you are yeah I did an hour and
a half bro didn't change [ __ ]
yes but me I don't know so it's like I'm
like let's do I was in someplace in the
Midwest and I was like who do y'all
don't like and he's like the Mormons hey
which I'll do for fun and it was like
nothing I was like hey we should put on
you should put on white sheets go to the
Mormon neighborhood and just burn [ __ ]
like what crosses and for fun and here
the whole y'all don't understand sarcasm
like that's what the KKK did for fun
away on from and then it was just got
tight and I was like oh so I'm used to
that get tight but over there in the
Middle East I know not to talk about
religion because that will get you
killed
yeah and some and some of the people who
had gone it wasn't Beirut it might have
been Saudi Arabia or somewhere like that
maybe Dubai and people were told that
you can you can pretty much say whatever
but don't talk about like dating you
can't even talk about dating because
people don't date over there and like
you can't talk about like walking and
holding hands or something they just
don't do this another Larry Omaha man
from Saudi Arabia from saying the word
God
yeah yeah that was the only death seek
god yeah yeah yeah yeah yank close the
mic on him he had to go sit in the back
and get on the plane that was all that
was the only death death over there
as somebody talked about God some local
and they they did oh yeah positively
you're not supposed to mention God right
the word God or anything like that
what dog dog you pray for this dog
doesn't do anything for you but bark
bark bark
I talked about being spiritual and
everybody just like you say five times a
day that was the most that was the most
started I've been just because over in
prayer breaks out you know I mean Arabic
like a song over the whole city and it
could be nighttime this quiet and just
like yeah you like oh what happened you
took a need for that
no well whoever sang that song it's hard
not to dance to as hot as a black person
that is it's hard but I feel if I
dancing on my you're not supposed to
have any sort of prayer and dancing or
anything like that
Islam chant yeah bring that up you know
it's dope though innit let it goes were
like oh no half hour you know I call the
prayer would be what it because yeah we
walked past one mosque I was going on
they just waved this we don't definitely
don't start like that's the one with a
belt down right you can hear all over
the speakers yeah yeah
there's like that I'm now commencing
movie when he goes to Mecca you need to
stop
oh right alone and we all know what they
say and shut up the studio but uh yeah
that is cool man
Iran yeah you don't know what's going on
you just like you just keep it moving at
that point they're gonna fender with
coupe d'etat jokes so yeah you know this
this how I determine what type of
comedian I am if I can go anywhere in
the world right even if I go with my
lady and I could not gonna be like where
is it a show here and somebody tell me
and I get booked on the show I was like
oh I might not I must not be that bad if
I can get a reference to like London to
Mexico to another english-speaking show
you know I mean to you know Israel to
Lebanon in these places I'm like oh I
might not be that bad you know no matter
how I get disrespected in LA and I go
and they get it and they laugh and it's
like oh this is direct connection to the
people and it says some about yourself
as a human being that's where it's at
you know I mean the bear to connect to
different people with different coaches
around the world to I know man I got an
email on Facebook from this lady who saw
my my comedy special in Tel Aviv yeah
and she said got most of it that's the
thing they will get most of it they get
there get it you know I mean it's some
amazing about yourself being able to
communicate especially our backgrounds
are kind of distinct she was telling me
about the struggles over there - like I
got you're struggling right hook because
then she was telling me about other
people you know like when I was she
related to it Oh like um another another
joke I said Oh over here is Armenians
yeah like she was saying that
it's very is very very poor over Israel
I mean it's a poor place versus like
across the border in Beirut where they
got everybody driving beam was in
Portia's and it's weird to see you know
me and then like they're separated by a
line but they hate each other
for somebody I've been I've been to both
countries you know me and they that's
like Haiti and Dominican Republic that's
just that line it's such a small island
they swear they don't share any DNA
yeah but you can you can see there's a
blood line there people share they but
the politics the hold the government is
all different though I mean are you I'm
from Georgia we hate Alabama human
nature that University of Georgia great
and you got the Crimson Tide which is
burgundy based on you know so it's
interesting so you came up with when did
you come to our you started our land in
Georgia at the punchline comes from
Atlanta Henry Welsh Harry wells yeah
yeah most feared most feared man to
parts dead
so truth be ideas dead but Rick smiley
still alive if you were to rappers you
said before to rapper in a comedian for
a long time [ __ ] throwing it you know me
and then you come here it just makes you
talk about whatever you want to talk
about cuz then if they if they throwing
[ __ ] at you in Atlanta for trying to be
who you are and they trying to groom you
to be something else you don't do it you
go anywhere else in the world you like
this is why I mean I mean y'all they
gonna donate what you can
I've seen people like getting fights on
stage every every other comedy city is
just calm compared to the you know you
steal jokes when I'm from his fight like
it's literally like fights if you come
close and you anywhere else is like no
it's not little keyboard warrior fights
on Facebook yeah it's a different
ballgame so it does something to you you
know heard of the line of you from I
grew up in I was born in Athens and then
I was raised in Atlanta in Clarkston
which is one of the worst cities in you
know but I don't think it's bad but
that's whether that's what a jail is you
know you've been downtown your lane I
got that big beautiful prison it looks
just like the one way I'm from you know
I mean that's their cuz so you were here
helicopters flying at night but they got
a gym inside it's beautiful you'll get
jealous you get jealous they live in a
life in there you know I get clothes I
get they get food every day you know so
it's cool I went to this um when I did a
show over there with um for American
Insurance Bill Bellamy we are the our
two after party right and as soon as I
got there I saw this man there were
police officers don't play over there
man no like this this guy was like six
four big like linebacker style you know
but the cop was 6-3 6-2 just as big
those shorter dude I saw him take out
that metal stick and I saw that let the
sharp end come out man
he started [ __ ] him up and I'm elbows
his wrists and his soldiers brought he
went there and I said nah that to the
driver nah we just go back to the hotel
room yeah
if it's that bad outside and was we
crazy right side it was the venue yeah
it's like an expensive two ones I
thought a thrill you get in there they
charge you bottle service I said 20 Rock
told me that he was walking with his two
bottles he didn't want to share no more
yeah he say he spent all his money there
here's the thing to that you'll see a
gay in a straight fight and it's the
same this is the cop you see two six
phonies
while we're heels on
yeah I don't know that when we got you
we got to the hotel it was nothing but
dudes bro yeah like all man in suits big
dude little dudes then didn't go to my
room somebody sweat oh man that was that
was hot laughing what you saw
yeah interesting our cops are cops are
black so our cricket club cops are black
you know me when I was young a sheriff
got voted out of office he was corrupt
so the winning Sheriff he showed up at
his at his home party and shot him in
front of his family god I mean that's
why we got voted out this is sheriff
that got voted out set up a hit at the
guys home so they was having a surprise
party for him so his family was inside
and when he got home it was just a
rabble of like gunshots you know and
that's like that's some of the stuff
that we came up in so you get to other
places in all the cops are like white
but it was a black city and they come
they have coming a car with the guns
drawn because everybody was toting by
the time you were a young black man you
22 like I know it's all my friends they
strapped because they can't legally be
strapped you not me and it's just a way
of life like people park their cars on
the grass because that's a private
property property if you walk on their
property they can legally you know shoot
you you know me so it's just like these
you learn these ways to survive that you
know now the Los Feliz and all free
buddies money man you know oh those are
some of the things that you were taught
like coming up in certain places because
I was born in a smaller town where it
was a little less of that Athens is a
college town yes I went there about
three or four times yeah orient our
friend I'm from Dallas I'm Keith Manning
he's from Savannah Georgia
yeah that's a constant and he told me
that he went to this other town he was
mad cuz abandoned was bad yeah I would
even he went lower solid in Georgia he
went to a town he was man it was all
black yeah he was mayor
cops schools so everybody warm up with
black manager general manager there was
nothing
you're just masking and black but it all
black it's like old
like that you know I mean that's what we
do that segregation still I don't think
so you know where I'm from it's oh
goodness you know they say there's there
were no white guys there
well the corporation that grab that
money though here's the thing a being
from a city like mine you hear you got
the separation like it's a lot of people
dr. King did well but well from it's a
it's a divided because they say he he
killed the black community by
desegregating everything you know so you
have those beefs going on under the
surface still still yeah because it's
leather still kind of segregated like
when I went in the comedy club is very
segregated people still sat down if you
look at the room it was but it's not
it's not institutionally segregated it's
it's a it's by choice by choice but also
mindset yeah look when people go out
white people go out and eat dinner black
18 still you know I mean 11 they go out
later at night you know I mean it's just
the way you just is in your psyche now
you just don't know that's how it is
you know I mean people just now coming
out the closet on interracial
relationships it's been my hand closed
doors for a long time you not mean
that's just what it is so you know I'm
gonna interracial relationship they
don't they don't say nothing too much
anymore they still like probably say
some hot cocoa and those three people
who live over there bro rather vacation
in Mexico in Hawaii yeah yeah they gotta
ye is like it's far-fetched but going to
Cancun that's like making a big step you
know me going to dr that's taking a big
step it's cool you know me like but
hawaii is like i'm not the first time
with the Hawaii I was like what is this
well these Asians come from weird you
know I mean so who knows and you get
more love in the dr you know i mean in
in mexico there's some of these other
places they watch your business oh bad
huh they want your business talk about
your business you could fly on the radar
they don't know like when i was in i
went to cuba we felt like we snuck into
cuba
they didn't know I wasn't Cuban long I
kept my mouth closed when I was in the
Middle East they didn't know that long
as I kept my mouth closed you know me
when you went to Cuba you creep from
Mexico yeah they got my as though
you flew yeah flew cuz if you missed a
flight if we missed a flight right
there's no committee connecting flights
so then that's when they find out you
know oh I need this flight they'll all
you need this flight it's gonna cost you
six hundred dollars more and you know
you buy a flight into Cuba late your
visa like twenty-five dollars but when
you miss your flight applies 250 now and
then you get the Cuba and there's no
they don't use pesos for tourists they
got a dollar call to see you see which
is American dollar plus ten percent so
they just hitting you over the head when
you want to buy some I had to legally
buy internet in the park
I had a homie that win over there and
for every hundred bucks they took a
twenty yeah that's what I was like it's
a timber it's a percentage on top of
your money and then you don't speak the
language so it just makes it even worse
you know
that's just what it is though but I get
it cuz when people when tours go to Cuba
which [ __ ] me up which I didn't like
people were going to the locals houses
see I didn't living to take pictures of
that and I was I could have went to the
praça I went to like so I could've went
to where I was from
like Athens Georgia if I want to hang
out in like these little apartments and
like you know people listening to music
and they were asked people for money
just to take pictures it was weird to me
so I never went in nobody house you know
I mean so the the people who live there
are offering it up that's a photo bomb
and every kind you want to let three
years ago yeah he was drinking with a
lady lady who kind of could could be his
mom to you because she was just like
skin right here same eyes because I
listen my grandma yeah man
then look or be home very very cool to
see my favorite part when my favorite
part is like when the kids and uh-oh
Havana was thrown
condoms were watering here at the white
tourists from the front of 3rd 4th
Street you know they got the little
alleys in this and it goes up the
balconies go up high and he was just
thawing and it was New Year's New Year's
night
I'm kids we're having a ball throwing
away wait I remember feeling Commons
over water you know I mean hitting tours
with him you know this is cool because
before they everything else I saw his
tours like you know taking pictures with
him and taking like some cultural
appropriation type [ __ ] which I do you
know I buy clothes in foreign I bought
like the Day of the Dead shirts over
there not weird like this is dope you
know me so you know but just to see
there was like this is like we were paid
back in a way how was the food in Cuba I
didn't I didn't care for it too much
myself you know they don't they didn't
have like some of the the fruit just
wasn't as sweet as the stuff we used to
because they can't import things you
know I mean forget it with Matt
fertilizer yeah so buddy I stopped
eating it when I got sick and I just
stopped eating and I remember I was like
just obviously drink water
which is a mistake then I'm having
diarrhea for five days you know I mean a
blast
yeah so I caught the flu over there
which was it was it wasn't it wasn't the
hottest thing in the world but
everybody's a business that's what
Sandra's mad hustlers if you got a car
you were taxi I mean we guys might $100
a driver six hours he stopped by his
house and kissed his daughter and his
wife like we're always getting kidnapped
we ordered a taxi and we like take us to
the top of that carry on taste which is
the top of the mountains right six hours
from the airport waited three hours on
luggage to arrive you know I mean people
bringing printers over and like weird
laptops and ink that they've trying to
bring into the country you know me or
you man and this guy we hop in this taxi
this guy he was straight iron shirt and
everything he's like I'm gonna get you
there and then he took this taxi out and
we met another taxi in the middle of
nowhere and it was dark and we he's
gonna take we ordered you then he was
like yeah but I got to go to work he's
gonna take you and then the guy we got
his cow he stopped he made another stop
and his mother-in-law came out his
daughter came out and his wife brought
him food and then from there it was just
like six hours going a hundred 100
kilometers understood kilometers flying
the dirt road little car you know seemed
on no seatbelt stop and smoke a
cigarette drinking coffee I'm like this
[ __ ] sleepy I wanna go my girl is
scared but I'm like when I see stuff
like that that level of danger and you
know whatever I'm like oh we we doing
something like this is the truth this is
the fun yeah this is the stories he's
sleeping you know I mean he's tired he's
swerving at 160 kilometers you know I
mean but we this is it this is the
journey this is what we pay for right
here you know we get there and everybody
sleep you get to the hotel four o'clock
five o'clock in the morning it's nobody
at the desk and then I hear just pop on
you yeah we'll check you in we get to
the hole we get in the room and they got
swans on the bay bay the towel and my
girl better co-directors who's like I
can't stay here
and I got the hotel because that's what
I can afford so yeah man I mean it's
interesting but it wasn't mine and his
last minute trip so we got got going
into the country we got got going in the
country because we took what's the
Mexican airline they have he got
Aeromexico yeah it'll be home they left
five hours late and everything we're
gonna miss the connecting flight and
he's like any more flights to five days
later so we had to buy flights while on
a flight damn
so she bought two separate flights on
one airline and I bought two service
like we bought four flights right and
then we missed the flight she bought and
we caught the flights that we bought and
they was like instead of $25 for the
visa two feet that was another 500 so
you missed the connection because of
them
because they didn't give a [ __ ] and I'm
like oh we just got raped going to Cuba
and that was just a precursor to they
didn't spend the rest of the trip but we
met people from Oregon they had to get
more
oh yeah y'all took the super deep you
know super deep but that's what it is
you'd make a last-minute trip my god
much research is not done I was cool but
it wasn't gonna prepare you for what you
know took place what took place
especially the way my lady lives you
know I mean it was good for me I
couldn't hack handle it because I'm
always like y'all thought that certain
things I won't accept like you know some
people were just like yeah when was that
Cuba trip that was last last Christmas
oh really no no no Christmas before last
cuz last Christmas we was in Mexico okay
you know how big was the New Year's Eve
celebration in Cuba well you know Castro
just passed so it wasn't as crazy as
they usually like but they fire cannons
like we was up at this castle and he
fired all these canyons which allowed
like like like cannon ball cannons like
Oh a few 60 cannons man the soldiers
they come out in March and he's lunch
these things I don't know how many shots
at work but it was just like boom go
over the city you know and then we took
a three-hour cab ride
you know I mean like these oh you know
how Cuba got the old-school cars that's
like old like 50 euro engines a lot of
bondo you know I mean they they put
those cars together yeah they put them
together man they'll show parts that
don't fit into that car to make it yeah
to make it they build a car around it
you like know if you know what a v8
sound like it don't sound like a
4-cylinder you in the car you is no
exhaust laws so that exhaust is hitting
you and you dizzy and then the cab
driver took us by his mother-in-law
house and we had to eat because we don't
want to be rude we had eat like these
cold pickle sandwiches a [ __ ] you know
need pickles [ __ ]
don't you I want to rent you for three
hours then that's gonna come with like
oh let me stop by let me kiss the kids
so they know that I'm not on her
cheating yeah let me tell you I'm gonna
take I'm gonna take all y'all to my
family house with my mother-in-law so
they can see and you got to sit there
and watch music videos
you only know what's going on you got me
it's like I hate to say it it's like
being on a and you have a hustle before
about drugs and sold drugs
it's like the initial meeting of
somebody for the first time and you in
their environment you don't know what
the [ __ ] going on you don't high alert
they're testing the thing is done you
know I mean it's like that situation and
then you like let's go drive us around
for more and they cook him pig in the
middle of the street they stick putting
on spike to a pig and they cutting it in
the middle of the street and it's good
so then it's smelling they just cranking
this [ __ ] for six hours and they like
you won't song you like you don't want
to be rude you like I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm eating with it it's a lot
of that going on were they good it was
good that part was good you can see that
but I mean if you was going to be a
different experience you know I mean you
speak the language you know so it's
different you know I mean oh and like I
said it's a last-minute trip other
people trip wasn't like that cuz it
wasn't so last-minute planning what's
outing they was with somebody they spoke
Spanish you know they didn't expect a
five-hour deal they had a handler
they're taking places taking places they
know what to do you know we was just
discovering his stuff for the first for
the first time you know I mean yeah we
were working I was working in Mexico we
they hired a local a local guy to take
us around yeah a fixer yep yeah Mexico
was you know me we had that guy we had
transport we decided to go to the Tia
Tess you want a pyramids which is
beautiful man and here's some historic
he's you know the guy family built the
pyramids the tour guide
you know I mean he got like multiple
homes with multiple wives I'm like you
in the game you in a game you know and
he took us to a cave and we did his
ceremony you know I mean that they do
another cave eight so those parts our
trips are beautiful when you see the not
the touristy part but behind the
curtains the culture you know I mean
trips yeah so that's what's important to
me like that's what you get in contact
with the people and you to me as a
spiritual being you learn a lot about
yourself you see how much alike human
kind are and the false or what other
tribes come in and trying to take over
the place because I feel we got all so
that's the thing you know I mean like me
coming from Atlanta where we fight
amongst each other socially economically
but black people don't get along you
know me and then go to a place like
Mexico or Laredo you see Latins don't
get along you go to to the dr and they
don't get along and you we [ __ ] up as
humans you know I mean we got a we got a
weird human condition that will always I
always have you're right it's a human
condition because even in what you're
saying is true even in black community
Latino community there's infighting
whether it's religion whether it's color
color shade of your skin even in the
same family
yeah like but it's a worldwide problem
they'll find something to fight about
yes I'll human nature that's the thing
but a part of a part of me was always
like why why we get treated a certain
way and this country they still shoe
know someone and then you are and then
you you try to escape and flee like oh
this is everywhere it makes me be like
alright well [ __ ] that [ __ ] complaining
about how we get treated and concentrate
on having a human experience and living
yeah man you know I mean go to eating
crickets go eat the crickets and see
what that's like
before they before you know I'm gonna
say before the cops shoot you is
everything caused me to live now you
know I got a cousin in prison I took him
on his first overseas trip he saw he was
in experience what life is like before
he got his teen years you know I mean so
is it it's like and that affect me cuz
I'm in LA I'm trying to diet and lose 10
pounds up and they like a [ __ ] up and
I'm like hearing a baby eat this street
meat again he won't have bacon-wrapped
hot dogs no more often I eat one of
these mother
he can have no Cuban water you don't
know when times up
you know I mean you don't they rate they
had to rave for french fries they had to
break in the security guard lockers to
steal french fries where you from that's
what they do they plot and plan on this
[ __ ] just for fries I'm gonna get these
fries
you know Tyson I'm gonna just check
these cookies it's a different community
within himself I'll be sending them
pictures like salads and [ __ ] cuz he was
[Laughter]
averse to smoke that with a bacon [ __ ]
I got my dress in yeah you get a contact
of weird we're flip phone still make a
move so interesting five cigarettes yeah
man what's up fool podcast yeah Byron
Bowers gang what's your histogram at
Byron bowels I'm at Byron bowels on
pretty much everything you said earlier
what you said something like do you get
respect and you get you felt like you
were so you were good you weren't that
bad basically when you could perform in
any sort of placement yeah contact
somebody and be like you know doing
shows here and they give you the
information what they call somebody but
then you also drop that you said you
don't get the respect you talking about
comedy soon well no comedy saying
respect me but as far as I always have
beef with dealing with like to me like
agents and managers and stuff like they
don't they don't get what I'm trying to
do or whatever you know me um that's
what makes it a little tough and
especially coming from a city where drug
dealers drop mixtapes and become you
know I mean you find ways to do it and I
feel I lose some of that and that's
that's what's good about the the Mexican
rooms they independently do it you know
I mean so you know it's like finding out
still how to independently make your
moves now I'm back on that [ __ ] when
before I was like trying to work with it
yeah trying to play the game
and that was like they don't get it and
they didn't they turn you down at though
cuz y'all don't see eye to eye on stuff
and it's not like you know I say what I
would call the Negro who'll be like yeah
whatever you want I do I'm like no let
me see the paperwork or now I want to do
that you know I mean he stopped sending
me this [ __ ] you know and it's like
oh you could you could you could become
difficult to work with which I'm not but
it just becomes it's a divide and I talk
about what the [ __ ] I want to talk about
you know I mean I talk about the
cultural things I seen or how ridiculous
things are you know um still you know I
mean like it's hard some things are just
hard for me to grasp mean I mean like
you don't want me to call you this you
want me to call you day and get you your
respect but it's hard because we still
getting shot by the cops and I mean are
you talking about gender a lot like
theyd that yeah my English and even that
good so we need to concentrate on the
program understand flavor though yeah
it's the thing like it's still but it's
still separation you want to be included
with yet you want to be called another
name and when I talk about stuff like
that a little [ __ ] you know calm down
all right no he's problem I'll call you
whenever
- he's problematic no when I first met
this fool they had a latino scene going
on there was like right before a bust on
TV okay locals which I now think is gone
because there's a Latino scene but it's
not like how it was before I was like
the originals yeah and that still hasn't
even got transcended but that was like
for real dawg
that [ __ ] was a lot of lying around the
corner paying five bucks to get in in
2001 you know what I'm saying about
those shows were [ __ ] bumpin yeah I
see I see and I don't really know the
depths of it well let him come with me
it go hard like it go hard I'm like man
this is crazy you got me my [ __ ]
swing fist though but it's because the
industry has been set up in such a way
or as works in such a way where there
can only be one where the world where
the dark side of calm like the and if it
was Star Wars Mexicans Latinos
we're like the darkside like they could
only be one right but back then it was
the thought in TV and movies one two
maybe three now there's more though at
the top there's still no Latino show on
TV yeah there's one on Netflix it just
barely made it second or third season at
a time I thought it was close
I thought the Latin was close to having
a day and then the Muslim she'd have
well then Trump came in also in them so
that's like let's get the opportunity
but yeah so there's this there's this
feeling and Felipe's mentioned it before
too like when he was on Last Comic
Standing he's looking at all these
comics and they sees cristela Alonzo was
in like the top 40 right yeah yeah and
he said that's my only competition
because they won't ever put two Latinos
in the top five and then were lots of
bullying is there - when he walked by a
little rail and a bunch of other
comedians like seven of them yeah he go
they can't take all you guys yeah that's
true but see that right there you talk
tequila baby [ __ ] with your head and I
see it a month I see them on the black
Hollywood here but my thing is I'm so
outside of it that you become dangerous
you dangerous when you outside of those
things you know I mean because the
tricks that they use the pin you against
one another don't work no more they do
that in the hood they pit us against one
another but once you rise above that you
do your own thing they don't know who
the [ __ ] side you own your untenable
yeah you you become untenable you know
me and put you on your back and even
even though even the black comes look at
you weird they look at you weird you get
it from every side I come a silverback
yeah you look at it from every side you
know I mean - so that's the thing so you
become you just outcast it from
everybody
then you see somebody you see like you
see like cardi B blow up right and then
you go she didn't have to change
anything nope right so now all these
people now they're looking for the next
cardi B now that's a big one now we want
somebody who's ghetto in cash but before
you're together know people better make
you yeah you know it's gotta be from the
people even with yourself with your
style you know me me coming in here like
being in Latin Rose I'm listening to
what people talk about and I'm here
Felipe dropping these gems like wow like
these straight shooters boom boom which
is the which is just straight up if you
didn't know anything about writing or
whatever
it's just a straight Universal style you
not me
and can twins like that on the low you
listen to can't wait you know jokes if
you take away your accent and you take
away cats pimp type [ __ ] it's just
straight comedy comedy and it's like
that's what's dope so that's what's dope
to me about somebody like yourself
breaking through you know I mean and
somebody like myself who's starting to
gain momentum in the city is like thanks
they gonna start to accept well see like
oh this is who this [ __ ] is do you know
me and why he's off a little bit yeah
yeah ain't manufacture like I'm bringing
you know all of the things that I
experienced with me like I'm not afraid
to say I'm [ __ ] up oh I got a little
monster I dealt with the drug game
before you know me almost blew a
building up in my early 20s no I say
that's it so that's one is like oh okay
okay and then they get it started slow
people started slowly listen be like man
you got some interesting stuff to talk
about so that's where I'm at now so now
where the community is like a man you
need to put out a special so humble own
blood that they could be
Howl's blew it up leaving even a piece
of peach ro that's not a Cuban water is
kind of long to get into but it'll been
uh just a rewiring of a few things in
the building to where somebody hit a
light switch go to have a nice little
light show anarchists cookbook doc
that's why I was at but I'm over that
now when I was young my mom let me play
with matches me too man
yeah noodles one time I went establish
Commedia at the Laugh Factory and I'll
planned out too but this year but I
couldn't do it because I couldn't
I would only work with another guy
another one really get to know ya see
just one just need one hand or the wrist
bro this is one little the I speak will
be perfect it says ass take it out
hand over the ice picture somebody and
I'm tell you about an extra hero never
thought it with me but ain't you glad
yeah for a spot at the mouth and it
could be like wonder it's something that
it's like common if you like I pull this
off it's like blessing the biggest but
then you know you don't
yeah yeah well that was a there's always
stuff like that that was just a dream
[Laughter]
that's what I like I talk about like
school shootings and stuff and I mean
cuz I know what it's like to have those
thoughts but I like nobody think about
the guy who wants to do school but can't
afford to cuz even school shooters are
privileged access to these things were
they getting those bomb-ass guns out
well go in there bro with my slingshot
bro if you do that'll be the [ __ ] a
slingshot mansion killed two cops on the
way out and then but it still be some
weight of all that David Goliath in that
thing oh yeah
right let's go David and Goliath how I
try to throw wrong like that once you
know what it's it hard to aim yeah when
to let it go and at what point in the
circle you know like how where it's
going to find the same thing with a
boomerang man the same I can't hear my
little boy around it I would never hit
anybody other boom if you miss it goes
back right if you miss it comes back
yeah succeed it'll kill or hit the
person or animal retrieving who was like
alright I threw lazy to go get that
[ __ ]
so if I if I just tweak it a little bit
it'll fly back to them genius how many
time he'd do it without killing other
people thousands actually flew back
it'll better than hardwood right yeah yo
ass dog you had a test it was Tollywood
I was a little steel Rock of Gibraltar
and the first guitar I didn't come down
Rick Lee back to you it went somewhere
else
killing the Yak with that [ __ ] dog
man that's a gangster as well some
gangster weapons in the history of town
some old club couple them all police
clubs them all of them oh like little
baseball bat yeah man billy clubs hard
leather with I think make no teeth and
eventually Heaven rolls in Mahalo Mahalo
Falls yeah a little blackjack bro like
this more Atlanta I think what your
prior got killed one of those in that
star remains the same no no no lady see
the blues the Buddy Holly movie would
you the heroin addict we hard really
hard they killed Buddy Holly is say vows
really holiday you got killed a little
middle rider yeah I won one of the one
of them they're illegal right they're
illegal but yeah you're supposed to like
it's to go like I think at the back of
the head back at lights out yeah real
quick right fled and it's covered with
leather you find those that's why but a
lot of the native tribes used to have
those little clothes yeah weapons are
all based on primitive weapon I was
until they made phones and irons that we
tell you to go with weapons now the only
weapon I use is my keyboard bro even on
keep Russian but it's funny you can want
somebody career whole life yeah it's
funny we were talking about this this
weekend the Michael che thing because
Michael che commented well he commented
that he's supposed to be hosting the
Emmys and but he commented on some of
the specials he didn't say anybody name
but he commented on how a lot of the
comedy specials on Netflix these days
are not comedy specials that woman shows
they're like they're like TED Talks
they're like lectures and he was talking
about he kind of got specific when he
said that you know rape jokes aren't
funny we all agree on the you know
what's really not funny rape stories you
know about real races well Hannah
Gatsby I think is her name but Bennett
no no that's the name of this special
cuz this woman and it's about a she
based it on some woman who treated her
like [ __ ] because of her gender and the
way she looks but he's totally right
though what he said he was like a lot of
these specials like the last three he
had seen aren't comedy I'm not laughing
at all and he's right and as much as I
liked Hannah's what she had to say it's
not a comedy special and it's just
and then everybody attacked Michael
because and it was all like yeah he
erased everything on his Instagram
deleted this Twitter yeah everything
just go yeah and and it's ridiculous
because he is totally right and in you
and I had this conversation a week
before he said anything and I said
know what I have to separate her talk
because her talk was important and it
had a lot of good points but it's not a
comedy special
it's not even though she had some funny
delivery and stuff in the first
half-hour
the rest of it it's a it's a lecture
like it's so distinctive in its like I
guess trying to give us insight on this
thing right but at the same time is like
um but the craft of comedy is turning
that into something funny you know it's
turning that oppression it's turning
that pain that you've gone through
whatever into calm that's the skill just
talking about it even if it's in an
eloquent eloquent way if it doesn't make
people laugh it's not a comment it was
breaking down comedy insurance that's
like sometimes people don't even want to
hear right but a lot of people want to
hear because I guess it was addressed
but I don't know man
she quit yeah she said she was going to
quit but I don't know but I don't want
to say I want you to come back my oh
that was a success they offered me to do
another one
you know I mean where's that boomerang
at it's scary though the way like if you
don't fight that though for HBO and he
had cancer and people was like you
better die you better die you better die
if you don't know people were waiting
people were asking him how his cancer
was going to but not genuinely concerned
they wanted to know when are you gonna
die I stack a special - because you
legit the laughter keeps me alive down
yeah that's the thing you know trying to
get that second special so that's why
don't do a second show
shows on some of these consoles so yeah
man I don't know man it's an interesting
game I'm not oh yeah I just got to get
in it myself
I gotta I'm gonna drop something I said
wait I just make a decree right now
Byron bow is gonna drop some people are
asking about it now and I just think
it's time Oh nobody gonna respond
because this is the same thing like what
you're talking about is right you have
there are agents out there who don't get
it managers who don't get it we pitched
his comedy special this last one we did
on HBO we pitched it I don't know he did
a showcase like two years ago three
years ago we were talking to different
people nobody was really interested I
can yeah
yeah but we wanted to capture it and so
we did it ourselves we paid for it we
hired the crew we did it we shot it and
then we had something to pitch to people
and then HBO wanted it well you sold but
they wanted to put it on HBO Latino only
and then and we said no and then they
came back and changed their offer but we
accepted him
we are nominated for a mocking oh my
gosh all about how that process when we
when we done cloud squires right Claud
Shire
Cyrus my lord he the squire the other
noble hit down bit to get rid not even
know that when I first met him 15 years
ago then I thought I find out his dad
yeah it's crazy yeah well you meet
people like that and you like oh you
should be making a Mitchell alligator ad
yeah I don't think he's getting the
money from that right now from the
second was invented coolers yeah my so
now I know the guy who invented gittery
and the guy who invented hot cheetos do
okay so general oh yeah that's cool
that's cool
Arab ties have dressing like a sheik
million yeah I don't know what I'll do I
did play till our last week and I didn't
get the numbers only one I got the last
one the one I know that 300 now Mega
Millions or I know Benny Gomez 500 a
Powerball is buy her new 300 million
last week
would you go 300 buddy residue also the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] no bill just like
dude it'll be crazy dawg oh here we go
bill disturber nation not pay taxes
would you build doc dude I would build a
compound for just my homies dog to live
and then I'll start like a political
action committee
oh I build the first mexican-american
prep school that's what I would do these
people like you that's how my lady is
this is people like y'all to get money
cuz y'all like this is what I'm gonna do
with it meanwhile more hoarded like I
would go to Italy watch I give my family
that finally traveling do not be afraid
to get on the plane and see some [ __ ]
and yeah but it'd be hard not to tell
them I won't tell them where the money
came from I can't be like I got that
type of fan I can't be like I got it
money so I gotta find that much money I
just be spitting it at people dogs no I
got a finally through some channels and
be like you know cuz you money you can
[ __ ] off and write off or whatever you
know in other ways yeah but you still
like the type of region that has or like
off things oh no they'll be conditions
to I mean don't be coming back with your
[ __ ] you know you got to do something
well so your brother may was a sort of
circus get in the mail an elephant dogs
a little cage a whip a chair it's like
poor baby if their mentality is off no
amount of money is gonna yeah like you
were talking about Paul his brother bro
mechanic batter mechanic fixing the
whole neighborhood car everybody
neighborhood he's always working all day
long poor Jake gets that for a real
garage by his immigrant garage under six
months see but see that was that he
wasn't at it he was part of the
community yeah it's like nobody showed
up but it's up to what you want to do
with it but when you're gonna try to
force someone to go to school and give
him money like if you're rich new kid
money to go to school and he doesn't
want to go to school this fool wants to
party
he's gonna party gilma so my I was a
weed and a thousand dollars which one do
you want can we get both my mom got
seven siblings right and my grandma
still alive so you come upon like some
money and you like here my if I can you
this chunk of money you could live for
everybody
they come like little baby birds I got
little brothers like that like when your
one last comic standing that dude hit
you up for his rent money because he
backed him up in a fight years ago human
now assaulting somebody I'll send you a
t-shirt dog you gonna when I hear what
happened to like people when they get on
is crazy like they'll be like like maybe
like a man some dudes was gonna rob your
mama last week but stop let me get like
40,000 that's why that's what makes it
hard for athletes that's the [ __ ] they
go through all the time you know girls
yeah your stories like roll like 30 deep
two places you know me now they got an
entourage now they got like oh yeah like
we had a rapper here from Atlanta cap
with a name cap G G from Camden yard
captain Park college yeah he's like a
Mexican do grew up in all black yeah I
mean yes like he stood out here the
jackal at this rapping with rapping and
he chose deep too huh a hundred fool of
him I understand no I understand I did a
Comedy Festival and I was wearing some
comics I think everybody was like
alternative like alternative facts you
know but yeah I don't forget it was like
Ferguson riots going on and I'm in like
this lovely ass place I'm in like a Y
somewhere and I was like man and they
not and it's like one of those things
like everybody you started off on the
journey with you're gone I know what you
mean mad about that feeling I get that
feeling a lot I was staying at the
Sheraton man in San Diego and it's like
it's right all the hotel rooms every
hotel room even on the cheap ones the
small ones you could to see the beach so
everybody gets to see the beach and I
started googling through what people
what person stood in his room what'd he
say and it was one brother man he were
from Wilmington or Compton man he just
hearing his face that he wishes people
could see this yeah well he say Rodrigo
I can't quote a word-for-word whazzup
man I wish I wish save your man San
Diego man sometimes a [ __ ] needs
to get out he goes man just having a
good time y'all and he forgets plug his
cigarette it is his coffee and it just
so you know he's not even like five
miles five hours away from his hood like
a two hour hour-and-a-half drive but it
just feels good to get away put your
foot in the sand [ __ ]
you know I always take people that come
from like Atlanta and like you feel feel
how cold is water you see what we go
through over here and uh and then I do
look [ __ ] like that just when they can
see how beautiful this place is
you know me and it is something about
wishing they were wishing they was here
because you know some people ain't gon
bear to see it I know some reason like I
was I will have the movie premiere for
for Amy Schumer movie girl
I guess girl pretty girl no you know the
moment oh there by myself ego it like me
and then to myself you know man I mean
in the [ __ ] movie I'm good what am i
walking through here I did some [ __ ]
or I want to leave already
but then I saw a fan a fan that was
happy brother see me and his excitement
here he worried to be where I was that
so I just say hey man what you doing
later ok that's your lady all right you
want to come with me to the red carpet
right now and just walk with me and I'll
give you [ __ ] two tickets to the
after-party and two tickets to the movie
yeah and he goes yeah so mad I'm a there
whatever I made their night I mean the
world have a cool a story one day for
and it felt good now because I felt like
you know another I shared my experience
stranger and you know I felt good about
it and I know that he felt good cuz he
still talks about it yeah what's the
next one yeah my best friend from high
school finally made the county for ten
years continued to hang out and that was
the last time I saw y'all I took about
area under his party naked men freedom
is a freedom that we don't we don't have
you know it's a freedom that people in
the barrios don't they can't even fathom
you know I mean because anybody weird or
different is shunned you do something
like that you're gonna get checked yeah
the [ __ ] yeah yeah man like I keep
telling the story when it when I did a
show for the homeboy industry for the
great boil they help these gangs get job
and they come out of prison I don't like
a gang prevention and I gave and I had
laugh at your tickets and said we're the
Laugh Factory at all man first of all
yeah through the 101 north [ __ ] that
homie I don't know [ __ ] up on the 101
north dawg
yeah you got any cheating you got
anything here in East LA or Montebello
six of five lawyers say no man it's
another world over here
pass the five South yeah but the only
you and a few others wanted to go into
that world you know you were craving
what's in Hollywood I just want to go
every man to man I will get up in the
morning
Saturday and my mom wouldn't see me all
day there's no Jerry got kidnapped
yeah for the last 11 hours I will hop on
a number one bus and take that
[ __ ] all the way through sunset
and Hollywood - Hollywood ends then I'm
just start walking all the way to
Hollywood and then go to Sunset do a
little shoplifting in Melrose bro you
don't silver rings Alamo get your beak
wet dog but there's no real barrier
there you can do it everybody in in your
hood can do it but they don't like even
the bothers the Bollywood make all their
money and that goofy in the hood however
I wasn't shouting on somebody that
forwarded a fight cuz he had a brand-new
car everything [ __ ] man your car
had a harder 20,000 miles on one Street
it's two videos I got my homeboys crying
because they love for the first time and
it was like man it's the same place it's
interesting man as Barry I took I took a
cousin with me I went to Japan I gave
him acid like Pam we was in a part where
our shoes on Japanese people were
staring and I was like oh this is what
the dogs take [ __ ] but we have we have
in a moment right now and he's staring
at a bird i watch these [ __ ] tearing a
bird and he was talking to a bird - is
mine right he got deep in the birds just
kept coming towards it step-by-step as
the bird gain trust and then he realized
oh she don't talking to a bird and he
looked back at me
see what's going on we on that frequency
yeah guess what he's scared of birds
scatter birds before that moment he
wasn't afraid of birds no mom my brother
has members in Ohio I have a brother
who's never got on a plane and he's
never left Ohio I don't even think he's
gotten under Cincinnati born people go
on vacation and they go at the same
spots yeah
oh the terrified Chipotle in Thailand
Cheesecake Factory that's all I want
that's not my other brother is he
travels only around the u.s. only a few
select spots so you can drive to
anyone's hard rock she's kidding
he to go to Cuba ask for apples we like
apples huh Apple okay
Apple we pulled out the phone in point
no we don't have you they don't even
have like like country like national
farms right they don't have did you I
heard what's bomb over there is pure
sugar cane juice well that's dope you
have a place in Chinatown he steals grow
these delicious tastes like just sugar
wobba wobba cheese and you know they
breaking them they breaking the
cantaloupes open what they're called not
the cantaloupes coconut coconuts open
and they still a little tart you know I
mean it tastes a little different
because the water supply whatever is
different over there so you know I mean
it's very interesting man if you go to
it you can find places like people
cooking people cook for in a home
that's my homeboy said you like you know
you get them groceries and they'll set
you up you show up at lunchtime to have
a meal for you have your rest of the
family you got dinner for you you go by
your ways $20 you can stay at the house
yeah and they wake up with a meal
meanwhile hotel it's like 380 yeah 380
that tours yeah yeah we we are not
getting a hotel
and it was like 380 or 4 for something
because they've got to get a cut to the
government yeah and and the Cohiba was
on one with the riviera and one was a
Cohiba the Cohiba was six something and
the but the locals like they're not
supposed to do that they're not supposed
to have a restaurant or a hotel or
whatever and because they are supposed
to give a cut to the government yeah and
they just don't do it all like on the
dome and I heard they're all like
straight up tighten it cuz the homeboy
said that the family that was cooking
for him it was like seven families they
had a little ahead of cow hide them
and like you know they have a little and
then they grown that way then when it's
time that you know they're right they
cut them up into piece that's the thing
yeah my um they split a goat it was
split goats and stuff like that 300 full
goat feed pop it in they will break it
up and that's not like that's because
I'm born in Athens that's a country town
so you know people was educated that's
how they made whatever you know me but
Cubano is like that you know I mean and
it's cool like even see that in there to
go go to somebody and be like we got a
ride somewhere he's like how much for
this and the guy was like give me this
much and I'll take you and we did and he
made us stop and pay the cell phone bill
with the money we just came yeah yeah
that's the type of like talk about check
by check yeah you know I mean they
getting it like so it made sense once
you understand the you know they're the
hustle and you to me like yeah you got
you got to land somewhere and pick up on
[ __ ] fast in certain places you know me
just letting you a cab driver before
lift right man Jack and everybody taking
the long way home
yeah always you got to tell them where
to how'd it what route to take in New
York I know how to get there you have to
tell no but they have you they have to
follow what you ask they have to take
your route if you tell him but a lot of
people don't know the routes they don't
say anything Beirut like that I called a
cab somewhere and
fifteen dollars and then I hopped on
Wi-Fi I call it over back for five Oh
was so full Byron here what's up ooh
what's goin now who give everybody your
instagram or twitter at byron bowers you
know twitter at byron bowels and
facebook is at byron by row G go at
Rodrigo the next show
August 7 in Riverside with Martina
Moreno at the Fox Performing Arts Center
8 p.m. and August 14th I'll be in
Temecula fool before we go man how
[ __ ] how will that show you do it
with Martine Amazon Oh with Rizzo and
Flaco fool it was like a sauna in there
dog it was a sod camera so hot like dude
the place was hot he was running you're
those window banger a sees the guy had
it ducted from the front door into the
little studio it wasn't a bigger than
here no yeah before we in here yeah it
not not here but a place this size but
you know just ratty and it was so hot
man so hard oh I brought a jacket to
look smaller
I couldn't wear my jacket dog I'm over
there out of melty dog shut up oh shut
up to that guy bull a memory the big guy
we met it's my it's my shout out to East
my hell from Oxnard homey thank you for
[ __ ] listening every week also take
you to Alex the great I like the large
another mega man for listening to us on
the night he's man from Ventura
yo yo yo this goes out when I think it
goes out I know I got two stores at the
Comedy Store tomorrow
crack him up Thursday was the black show
and I'm gonna hop over to the white room
and do a show you know I mean I'm also
gonna be at the Laugh Factory in Long
Beach LBC in the house Pine Street you
know I mean I know y'all like that
trying to buy new shoes and [ __ ] we out
there doing our thing ice cream Pine
Street you know I mean so yeah I but I
got like like eight shows this week so
yeah go to my website
Byron Bowers live.com and then check it
out and pop up and say what's up fool
say how he said I know what's all fool I
know where you come up just hit him up
man
awesome man I might be doing a little
music video bro with
mezcal itto address bulldoze this
weekend Cinco puntos Cinco puntos litter
by the peano that's the most crazy in
neighborhood where that Mexican
restaurant is because there's a there's
a there's a cemetery right and there's
people who jog on that cemetery right
for years about judging a cemetery yeah
and now why people move in and they had
a track the cemetery has our actual
track around we could jog right cuz I
remember man and summer like - yes that
that uh that uh that neighborhood is
still it's still bad though I don't give
a [ __ ] if you put a track or anything
that when you when you were jog there
when you were younger you couldn't be a
thug and jog because every section of
that cemetery was owned by a different
neighborhood like the other side
Whittier was White Fence then this side
was easterly tiny dukes and the other
side was some other gang I didn't know
cuz I never winner or evergreen so
manner just like a little history about
that cemetery man also there's a lot of
dead homies in that cemetery cuz it was
a Jewish cemetery was it a Jewish
cemetery before or just had some Jews
Serbian a crank Serbian but it wasn't
like an official Jewish yeah that uh
that that signature is called assumption
right there on the other side on this
we're like somebody served me were
border were buried there any know where
they came from but now his white friends
and tiny do's and Madame caskets for the
guns and they brought them over in ages
bury ghost what's up fool coming up in
the future on the podcast we're gonna
have that gap my friends bro thing
he's been doing little while testimony
here on early homes here Louie boom bro
mark mark do this fool has mad history
dude mad like he's telling us clean yeah
he likes heroin addict but he's cool but
you know this without trying to bag
start bagging on this fool oh my god
this hilarious dude that's funny right
he hangs out there he's security guard
at that we chop right and like he looks
crazy right boy he leaves he puts his
good teeth on bro I would easily working
he's looking like he has bad - you gone
right - look crazy bony leaves bro look
pretty smiling and the old school like
starch oh my god those oh my god like
just the way he has his creases and the
way does yeah - creases and a free
t-shirt he has two creases in the front
- a one crease in the back the middle
like a pennant and one crease on the
sides and his pants are creased and if
the box stars are creased
he was Levi's his Levi's look like his
Levi's look like doctors but they're I'm
creased if my socks are former cholos
started dry-cleaning shops because they
could be some badass iron that doesn't
exist anymore back in there a little kid
all the cholos are all perfectly present
even the panel tense there like like
Birdman still cares about that yeah then
why bang guys but you still see the
little crazy little cholos who weren't a
big-ass white t-shirt dog yeah don't get
close yeah maybe once in a while man you
see some payload as Echo Park gangster
walking around nowhere dude but it looks
it looks out of place now though just
like Anton [ __ ] are coming come on yeah
it's like coming
everybody says that shit's gone it's not
gone yet I remember when they started
banning khakis cholo started wearing
Dockers then they banned Dockers three
house parties and they've been wife
beaters so then they wore jerseys yes
I've been to I would took a couple of
clothes no likey and I'm Kansas and
we're in Georgia where is the whole sign
was the dress code for the Lucas cause
my whole Jersey no hats
remember all those old-school same thing
in Ohio and they know how I'm from they
have the same thing all the dress code
no hats you couldn't have me on my
school in my junior high school we
couldn't have colored shoelaces they
felt like that was communicating with
other gay men our color with red cars
were black and gold
I was gold letter with a hook for the R
and then the whole hat with red but yeah
they were there were I guess there are
Crips and bloods but I knew a lot of
drug dealers in my high school and stuff
but not gang members I mean I didn't
know any gang member said shoulder
thought it started changing started
dressing like regular foods once they
were like being chased by the police
yeah once I realized they were cuz I
remember this guy named polo my mom
reminds to babysit their food bro
therefore we're in a shooting spree bro
and later on I saw him walking Hill
wearing overalls with a nice nice nice
domme t-shirt Dockers boots and a hat
dude looking like a hipster the 90s
in a Trapper Keeper yeah what that
change those cholos have backpacks now
with guns and pounds of weed inside
what's up fools shoutout to Baby Bash
wherever you at dog hit a baby bass tell
him we said what's up kid for us for
being a gas cap G Byron balling right
here a helicopter what's up fool it's
getting crazy here shout-out to Toby
Hicks the dope dealers podcast yo your
your podcast and George Perez was a
little goatee